Alhamdulillah.
My respected elders and my dear brothers
and sisters, I welcome all of you with
the Islamic greetings. Assalamu alaykum.
May peace, mercy and blessings of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala of Almighty God be
on all of you. Today inshallah
I'll be speaking on the topic
misconceptions about Islam part two.
Yesterday I spoke on the topic
misconception about Islam part one and I
discussed there that da'wah which means
to convey the message to the non-Muslims
which means to invite the non-Muslim
towards Islam is fur on every Muslim as
Allah says in surah assar chapter number
103 verse 1-3 that one of the criterias
to go to Jenna is dawa
it's a duty of every Muslim to convey
the message of Islam to the non-Muslim,
invite them to the fold of Islam. And
there are various different
methodologies
of doing dawa. Some are less effective
while the others are more effective. The
most common method used by Muslims is
that whenever they meet a non-Muslim,
they
speak 100 good things about Islam. And I
mentioned yesterday that even if the
non-Muslim agrees with those 100 points
of Islam, yet at the back of his mind,
he will think, "Ah, you are the same
Muslim
who's a terrorist. Ah, you're the same
Muslim who's a fundamentalist, who's an
extremist. You are the Muslims who
spread your religion with the sword. You
are the people who marry more than one
woman. You are the people who subjugate
the woman by keeping her behind the
wheel. These few negative points at the
back of his mind will prevent him from
accepting the beauty of Islam. That's
the reason whenever I meet a non-Muslim,
I ask him upfront, what do you feel is
wrong with Islam? And I make him
comfortable that he can ask any
questions. He can criticize Islam. He
can attack Islam. You know, I can take
it. I'm young. And after I make him
comfortable, he poses about three or
four questions regarding Islam. And
invariably, these questions fall amongst
the 20 most common questions asked by
the non-Muslim regarding Islam. And in
my past more than 30 years of my life
that I've been giving public speeches,
interacting with non-Muslims in
different parts of the world, I have
realized that there are 20 most common
questions or 20 most common
misconceptions that the non-Muslims have
regarding Islam. And if a Muslim knows
the reply to these answers of these 20
most common questions based on the
verses of the Quran and the say hadith
quoting the scriptures of the non-Muslim
with reason and logic and giving
scientific evidence even if he cannot
convert them even if he cannot revert
them he can at least neutralize the
animosity that is mind that is there in
the minds of the non-Muslim regarding
Islam.
It is preferable
to know the answers of the 20 most
common questions rather than know the
answers of the 200 uncommon questions.
And my book is available on this topic.
Even the video cassettes are available.
And yesterday
we discussed the replies to the first
nine most common misconception and these
top of the charts keep on changing
depending upon how the media portrays
Islam. And we know today there is intern
there is virulent propaganda regarding
Islam in the in the international media.
Whether it be international newspapers,
international magazines, international
radio stations, television channels,
whether it be the social media, we find
there is propaganda regarding Islam. And
depending upon how the media portrays
Islam, these 20 common questions keep on
changing. Before
9/11, before 11th of September year
2001, the most common question was why
does Islam allow a man to have more than
one wife? But after 9/11, the most
important question became jihad. Muslims
are terrorists, Muslims are
fundamentalists. So depending upon how
the media portrays these 20 common
questions are same irrespective whether
they go to USA to Canada to Europe to
Singapore to Saudi Arabia to Dubai to
Africa to Kenya to Nigeria to India to
Pakistan. These 20 common questions are
the same. There may be an additional one
or two questions depending upon the
society. Like in USA they may ask why
does Islam prohibit the giving and
taking of interest but the remaining 20
common questions will be the same.